he's Ernie Johnson Turner Sports host
host of inside the NBA outstanding
sports personality host the winner of
the Sports Emmy four times and he joins
us on the program
Ernie how are you today KP I am about as
well as you can expect and I hope you're
doing well too we're doing okay do you
have a man cave at the home I have an
office I don't really call it a man cave
it's it is an office that has you know
the TV and has my my work stuff in there
and memorabilia and that kind of thing
but I just usually spend a lot of night
you know late nights in there when I'm
doing research and that kind of thing
and homework and when everybody's asleep
but yeah it's not it's not a full-blown
man cave because people can walk past it
all the time kids can walk in and
grandkids can walk in dogs walk in so
it's my version do you collect sports
memorabilia not you know not
intentionally really it's kind of crazy
I I have a lot of stuff through the
years and I don't know if you do the
same thing but you know I'll I'll throw
something in a box I threw a credential
in a box and I'll throw various things
and and the other day are actually over
the last few months my wife and I have
kind of said unique she said you need to
get rid of some of this stuff it's in
the basement
or and so we have a room that's kind of
set aside now and I went through it the
other day and I was amazed at some of
the things that I had kept dan you know
I was started in the radio back in the
70s and in 1977 I was working at Q 105
radio what happens and I actually kept a
desk calendar one of those with the flip
over pages and I in a box in the bottom
of a box was this desk calendar so I
started looking through it and then I
needed to call bill kratzert immediately
because bill was a great golfer at the
University of Georgia I would later work
with him 25 years later on the PGA
champion
but it was a note for this December day
that was going to be bill kratzert day
at the University of Georgia golf course
and I needed to go and it was it was
just very bizarre that was kind of like
you know what it's kind of a good thing
that you hold onto some of this stuff
I've been able to throw some away but I
do have some things that kind of have
some meaning you know after after years
a year I can't throw stuff away I mean
that's why I have the man cave I moved
into a big man cave or bigger man cave
just because I have all of this stuff
that I collected and I one day it might
come in handy and it has because I I
have a chance to show it all off and I I
don't know what I'm gonna do when I
retire because this is a I am the best
man cave anybody has I'm sure I'm sure
it's crazy you know you know what you
know what's ridiculous is that I come to
this I I had this dilemma I'm standing
in the middle of my basement and I'm
trying to decide if I should throw away
this Goodwill Games t-shirt from Russia
that has a bunch of mysterious you know
like coffee stains and dirt on it and
I'm saying well I can't really hang it
up and I want two people to but I can't
really throw it away there's so demerits
back in a box and it's hidden from my
wife sir why don't you film this Ernie
why don't you why don't you do a kind of
a virtual tour of all the things that
you might be throwing out I thought
about doing that I thought about going
down into the because Billy I now have
like these two rooms I have the office
upstairs and I have this place in the
basement downstairs a room that we
finished where I have hung a few things
up you know you've got a caliber in
Jersey down there and I've got a few
other you know things that hats from
various events and memos that would I
have memos from Turner in the 80s you
know that I've that I've held on to and
there's just part of me that says don't
let go of that and so yeah it would kind
of be it would kind of be a fun virtual
tool and these days we're all looking
for fun virtual things to do absolutely
Ernie John
Turner Sports host and a host of inside
the NBA what do you miss most about Shaq
his laughs probably and the joy he gets
out of coming into work and trying to do
something that gets two billion YouTube
hits I think I think that's probably but
you know I kind of missed them all for
the same reason I miss him and Kenny and
Charles all for that same reason that we
just have this kind of this I can't
describe the bond we have but I've told
people that I grew up with two older
sisters and this is as close as I'll
ever come to having brothers and I just
miss hanging with them and you know it's
like you just miss the little things
about being together and doing and doing
the show and you miss the you know the
215 comments about you know from Kenny
you know threatening the producer said
we better hurry up these last two
segments I got to get out of here at
2:15 in the morning so I miss all that
stuff if I would have told you a month
ago this is where we would be with the
NBA what would you have said I think I
would have I think I would have believed
that at that point I mean it because it
really has been you know it's been a
month and that night that that there
were no games for the first time the
night after the the suspension and we
had Adam silver on the show and just the
vibe that we got from him and talking to
him was you know hey this is a this is a
great unknown and we just kind of have
to wait and so I never thought at that
point that hey maybe in a couple of
weeks things would be back to normal but
then when I spoke to him earlier this
week again we had a we had this
initiative called hashtag NBA together
in which we you know we just kind of
catch up to people around the NBA might
spend 15 20 minutes might spend a half
hour with him on the phone and and I
asked him that same thing I said that'd
be no any more than we knew when we
spoke a month ago and he's like not
really did I know enough to say that I
don't we're not going to have any kind
of a decision in the month of April
about where we're going and so yeah
it's um I just I just hope we're all
coping the right way and I know you know
look can I be totally honest with you
then I've been okay I've been
inconvenienced I can say that look there
are people out there who were really
really struggling during this time you
know we've been inconvenienced by a
schedule I still AM able to do work from
my house you know to do these interviews
and to do like a virtual journalism
school for for college kids and and and
you know we're doing okay but man my
heart just goes after those folks who
were who were hoping that you know a
ventilator shows up and that place masks
show up man it's this is this is very
hard I mean I'm watching I watch that
movie Contagion the other night I told
myself I wasn't gonna do it
and the neighbour said you should watch
it and it's amazing how this 2011 movie
mirrors what what what we're looking at
now in many respects you can see Ernie
interviewing some of the biggest names
in the NBA on episodes of hashtag NBA
together Mondays in Wednesday's visit at
NBA handle on social media co-host of
the steamroom podcast with Charles
Barkley also Ernie has his journalism
school and you can find out more at
Turner Sports EJ I thought about you
yesterday we had Hank Aaron on and you
know the anniversary of him breaking
Babe Ruth's record and he was one of my
just one of my favorite people he's 86
years of age and I thought of your
father too you know longtime broadcaster
for the Braves and then I thought a
Craig Sager cuz sagres on the damn field
at home plate with a white trench coat
and I'm going only Sager could do it and
I think yes is a little portable radio
microphone that he's holding up as it's
still so soot surrealistic where two
guys run on the field
Hank is trying to keep his dignity
rounding third heading for home and
there's Craig Sager chasing him to home
plate with the same haircut
Eggar went wire to water with that he
went wire to one yeah never changed and
it was and it is amazing to consider
that because when you think about these
days and and and obviously how tight
security is at all people but a guy
could run out with that trench coat with
a Radio Shack tape recorder
no visible credential and that haircut
and speak with Hank Aaron as he touches
home plate is absolutely stunning I know
back did the hammer remember Greg in
that in that scene at the plate he said
one of the guys who came onto the field
became a doctor he remembered his mom
holding on tightly I didn't bring up
Sager but I'm sure Hank probably is
wondering I got all my teammates out
here my mom and some dude in a bad
haircut in a trench coat but I think I
think Craig actually did get like a
usable couple of seconds out of that
from from hearing the the playback later
because you could hear his question like
and then you hear like you know people
you know kind of going crazy around him
but that was sex you know that was a guy
who's like if there was a big event
anywhere he wanted to be there even if
we weren't covering it and back then he
was what he was a radio guy in Florida
somewhere yeah we'd got who had gone up
there to see I'm going to cover this
game but who knew that you know his
designs were to actually you know greet
Henry at play it was it was that is one
of those that was one of the classic
it's almost like if you were watching a
movie where a guy was dreaming about he
wishes he wished he had been it at the
ballpark when Henry heard at 7:15 and
then he envisioned himself as this guy
it was a real-life deal for sakes man
that it's again I shaved my head and it
just brings a smile in my face because
that's the
as the waste legs went after it man you
know it didn't have to be an assignment
like your Turner for him to be at a big
event he just loved it he truly loved
going to those events I'll leave you
with this and but where do you think
we're gonna get to where we're at the
point of no return with trying to
squeeze in playoffs here with the season
you got a feel for them I don't know I
tried to I tried to get that I tried to
get you know really kind of any kind of
a timeline from the Commissioner the
other day and it could probably be you
mean he'd be all speculation so I can't
I don't either but I'm looking at it and
I'm saying you know where do you know if
you come back if you come back in in
June and I don't know I mean can you
finish a regular season that's why there
are so many variables can you finish a
regular season and give a team like the
Portland Trailblazers that's number nine
right now a chance to move up to eight
over 15 games I don't think you know and
then you saying how is this going to
impact next season you know then then
how do you want it so I'm not so DP I'm
I'm not trying to dodge it I am trying
to dodge it because I don't want to put
something out there that suddenly people
are saying oh I think he thinks it's
going to start in June I have no idea
and I then I and I told the Commissioner
the other day I said look if you know
I've heard all these things about going
to Vegas and having a tournament and all
this stuff and Quarantine and the team's
eyes and I just said unless we can be
absolutely certain and and and that
every medical official has signed off on
this and said it's not going to be a you
know a danger to anybody's help
well you better be sure because as long
as there is the possibility yeah there
were worse things in the world than then
not being able to crown a champion in
the NBA this year you know I just think
for the greater good you've got to
consider all that so I hope we'll back
plan but man there's there's a lot more
there's a lot more stuff to consider
these days it's that weighs a lot
heavier than that hope the family's
great always great to talk to you Ernie
thank you and hopefully talk soon and
have some basketball to talk about
yeah we're doing well here hope you guys
are too and we'll get through this and
yeah well we'll talk again and I'll
maybe I'll give you a virtual tour of
that room
I can't wait thank you that's Ernie
Johnson TNT